MAN: Rained in a
little from this wall.
So I'd like to
build this wall in.
I think I'm ready to go
chop down another tree.
So found a widow maker.
Usually I look around
my shelter and I'm like,
I don't see any branches.
I remember doing this.
For some reason,
I missed this guy
right here that is in direct
deadline to my shelter.
And being in a storm, that
could have easily smashed me
and make me a widower.
I don't know.
Kill me, dead.
When I chop this, it could
land right in my shelter.
Smart thing to do would
be to take off my tarp
and then try to
fell it after that
just to make sure that it's
not going to take my shelter.
I'm not going to do that.
Wish me luck.
Idiot!
I'm an idiot!
The most intimidating
thing about this location
is the weather.
That crazy storm
concerned me a lot.
It's just going to get worse.
Right between the two trees.
Good, good, good.
I want something that
I feel comfortable in.
I want something that I
don't have to worry about,
crazy storm comes in.
But you know, if the bear
starts pounding on it,
I want something that's
going to keep me safe.
Here it goes.
Oh crap.
Ha!
And I was concerned.
Another tree's going to
fall right on my head.